this video introduces Saku lee an
interactive technique that uses
screenshots to search and automate
graphical user interfaces
Sakuni search allows users to search a
documentation database using screenshots
of interface elements like this dialog
box the user draws a rectangle around
the dialog box to capture its screenshot
and submit it to Sakuni sakuni currently
searches a database of more than 50,000
screenshots from over a hundred computer
books it then returns a list of pages
containing the screenshots of the same
dialog box the user can browse and
select a page to read the details about
the style Sakuni script allows users to
write simple scripts to automate GUI
interaction by screen shots consider
this bus tracking interface with sakuni
script a user can draw a rectangle
around the bus symbol to take its
screenshot and select a neighborhood on
the map to watch for the bus arrival
also by taking a screenshot
after taking the screenshots the user
can use them directly in a statement
asking Sookie we've defined the
neighborhood on the map look inside and
find the bus symbol if such a symbol is
found a pop-up window can be displayed
to notify the user the bus has arrived
Sakuni script supports many visual
commands it can be used to click on
visual targets to drag a visual target
onto another visual target
to type a string in a visual target in
this case the Google search box in the
web browser with Saku Lee what you see
is what you search and what you see is
what you script